more than six months after a deadly
massacre at a buffalo grocery store the
victim's families may be finally getting
some justice the shooter pleaded guilty
yesterday to charges including domestic
terrorism and admitted he was motivated
by racism jerika Duncan reported from
Buffalo after the massacre and she's
there for us again this morning jerika
good morning
good morning a very tough day for those
victims families prosecutors say that
the gunman drove more than 200 miles
from his home and came here to this tops
behind me to terrorize a community well
six months later as you mentioned a
small measure of justice for the
families left behind
it is important for this community to
hear how these precious lives were
snatched from us the now 19 year old
gunman who in May killed 10 people
inside this Tops Grocery Store admitted
Monday that his actions were motivated
by his hate for black people he even
went so far as to do a group Google
search
of the ZIP code
in New York state that had the highest
concentration of African-Americans
prosecutors say he planned the mass
shooting and visited the grocery store a
couple of times beforehand at night time
when I miss her the most
I want to God Barbara Maps is the sister
of 72 year old Catherine Massey who went
by cat in court yesterday she and her
niece Adrian Massey set through the
prosecutor's gruesome details of where
their loved one was shot and when
he shot cat
110 pound cat
in her back her head twice
I miss my sister so much
thank you
why be in that courtroom I have to be
there to represent my sister because
everybody in a minute is going to be
touched by this
yeah
every every time you turn around how
messy died was tragic unexpected and
painful but her family says going
through old photos and videos of how she
lived
are what keep them moving forward she
wasn't cool oh she cool okay cool like
that she was cooler than a cucumber cat
was a wonderful sister a wonderful cat
was just a good person
the killer still faces federal charges
which could end up with the death
penalty in a statement his parents said
that they are heartbroken by the
devastation their son caused Gail
yeah we're still all heartbroken about
that Sharika thank you